[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's brief video we're going to be
taking a look at harry potter's first
encounter
with the afterlife more specifically
we're going to be discussing
harry's experience with well death and
explaining
what he saw and took in during the brief
period that he spent
in limbo in case you had forgotten harry
of course dies
after traveling to the forbidden forest
to meet voldemort
harry looked back into the red eyes and
wanted it to happen now
quickly while he could still stand
before he lost control
before he betrayed fear he saw the mouth
move
and a flash of green light and
everything was gone
the next thing we know harry is
beginning to regain consciousness
from here he quickly realizes that he's
no longer in the forbidden forest
in fact entirely disoriented he didn't
know where he was
all he knew was that it was unlike any
other place that he had been before
he lay in a bright mist though it was
not like mist he had ever experienced
before
his surroundings were not hidden by
cloudy vapor rather the cloudy vapor had
not yet formed
into surroundings the floor in which he
lay seemed to be white
neither warm nor cold but simply there
a flat blank something on which to be
his environment was completely surreal
and harry had lost all of his bearings
in fact
he had no idea if what he was
experiencing was real or just a figment
of his imagination
this is reflected in his exchange with
dumbledore before returning to life
tell me one last thing is this real or
has this been happening inside my head
to which dumbledore replies of course it
is happening inside your head harry
but why on earth should that mean that
it is not real
however before leaving the afterlife and
sharing a lengthy
enlightening discussion with dumbledore
harry notices something
then a noise reached him through the
unformed nothingness that surrounded him
the small soft thumpings of something
that flapped flailed and struggled
it was a pitiful noise yet also slightly
indecent
he had the uncomfortable feeling that he
was eavesdropping or something
furtive shameful harry turned slowly on
the spot
and his surroundings seemed to invent
themselves before his eyes
he had spotted the thing that was making
the noises it had the form of a small
naked child curled on the ground its
skin
raw and rough flayed looking and it lay
shuddering and the receipt where it had
been left unwanted
stuffed out of sight struggling for
breath he was afraid of it
small and fragile and wounded though it
was he did not want to approach it
nevertheless he drew slowly nearer ready
to jump back
at any moment soon he stood near enough
to touch it
yet he could not bring himself to do it
he felt like a coward
he ought to comfort it but it repulsed
him
you cannot help he spun around albus
dumbledore was walking toward him
sprightly and upright wearing sweeping
robes of midnight blue
and the thing that harry had witnessed
on the floor whimpered throughout his
conversation with dumbledore
wriggling around pathetically so what
you may ask
was the small naked child on the floor
of harry's own ethereal version
of king's cross many fans believe that
the child on the floor of king's cross
was in fact the part of voldemort's soul
that previously resided within harry we
know that harry carried a piece of
voldemort with him for his entire life
and so it seems to make sense that with
harry dying in this soul shard now
destroyed
it would follow him to the afterlife
however though this is close to the
answer
it's actually wrong according to jk
rowling the being stuck in limbo with
harry
wasn't the horcrux within himself but
rather the current state
of voldemort's soul what exactly was the
mutilated baby-like creature harry saw
at king's cross
in chapter 35 of hallows i've been asked
this a lot
it is the last piece of soul voldemort
possesses when voldemort attacks harry
they both fall temporarily unconscious
and both their souls
harry's undamaged and healthy voldemort
stunted and maimed
appear in the limbo where harry meets
dumbledore
in essence it's a representation of
voldemort named soul
rather than the peace of destroyed soul
that resided within harry
the most common interpretation of
harry's run-in with this odd creature
voldemort lived a cursed life where he
would routinely rip his own soul apart
in pursuits of immortality and such acts
come
at a great cost the pathetic wriggling
child
squirming along the floor was all that
was left of voldemort's soul
and that's it for this video did you
know the answer to this already
did you know the most commonly thought
answer or the actual answer
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
of course it is happening inside your
head harry but why on earth should that
mean
that it is not real
you